- [Abbas] Good afternoon, everyone.
- [MICHAEL] Good afternoon.
- How's everyone doing?
- Great.
- Great, awesome.
Well, thank you for joining us here today.
This is, I appreciate the time.
This is live streamed and recorded,
and just looking forward
to a real discussion
on healthcare and all the new innovations
going on in AI and agents.
And we're, this is not
one of those sessions
where we will not bring up AI, right?
I mean, this is front and
center in our lives right now.
So first of all, it's a
privilege to be back here.
This is our fourth year in
a row we've been doing this
and I'm humbled to be here
with four esteemed leaders
at four organizations,
representing 16 of our states in the US.
And without further ado,
let me start with introductions.
Mike, do you wanna just
introduce yourself,
your organization, and span of control?
- Sure, thanks, Abbas.
Mike Regan, I'm the
chief technology officer
for Banner Healthcare.
I'm kind of responsible for
traditional IT digital data
and all tech ventures.
I just finished my year and a half,
so I guess now it's all my responsibility.
I can't, you know, claim I inherited it.
But I've been in healthcare
for over 20 years,
and been with four great organizations
before joining Banner,
started my career at
Providence Health and Services.
Went to Cleveland Clinic and was CIO
of their international site
at Cleveland Clinic Abu Dhabi.
And then went and learned
the payer side of healthcare
with Sentara in Virginia.
And most recently, before joining
Banner Sharp Healthcare in San Diego,
really honored to be here
with a great bunch of colleagues here.
- Geoff.
- Good afternoon, Geoff Hook,
I'm the chief information officer
for Nuvance Health in
New York and Connecticut.
We are now part of Northwell,
and so my span of responsibilities are
data, AI, analytic security
and the overall technology stack
for the legacy organizations.
We look to see how we
bring the organizations,
between Northwell Nuvance together,
my history is IT and process
improvement and statistics.
So I love what AI and
data is doing for us.
I just wish we could figure out
how to make it more practical.
- Good afternoon, everyone, Raj Nair,
CIF for WellSense Health Plan.
We are based out of
Massachusetts and New Hampshire,
part of Boston Medical Center.
In addition to CIO responsibilities
for the health plan,
I'm also part of
the Boston Medical Center
technology leadership.
You know, overall team.
Super excited to be here.
My second time doing the panel,
after last year, I wasn't sure
Abbas will invite me back, so.
- His nickname from last
year is, Ruthless Raj.
So I'm just gonna call
you out there again.
- And I'll echo what Mike said.
It's a privilege to be here
with some awesome leaders, here.
- Now I know I'm setting at the end
of the line next to him.
Hey, good afternoon everybody.
Andy Crowder, chief AI and digital officer
for Advocate Health, Advocate
Health is a new name.
It's a merger of Atrium
Health and Advocate Aurora.
We're now the third largest
health system in the US,
with 165,000 teammates,
we operate in nine states,
over 10,000 providers and about
75 healthcare, 75 hospitals.
I oversee all digital
solutions, software development,
APP dev, strategic partnerships,
direct-to-consumer digital initiatives,
and the overarching AI
strategy for the health system.
Nice to be here.
- Wonderful, and just a
quick intro on myself,
Abbas Mooraj, I'm based out of Boston.
I'm a proud alum of
Mass Gen Brigham and
Optum, part of United.
And I've been, I serve as
the cloud data and AI leader
for health services for PwC.
All right so, let's get into it.
This is gonna be, we're
gonna go on a journey from,
how do we even get to AI, right?
There's no good AI without good data.
You heard Matt Garman,
you've heard many leaders
talk about that today,
we're gonna talk a little bit
about the new announcements
that Matt and team made.
Can't wait for Swami's keynote
tomorrow morning, as well.
And then we're also gonna
talk about the value creation,
value realization of
AI at a health system,
which is in dire, dire needs
of not just modernization,
but there's so many margin,
there's so much margin pressure.
There's now tons of regulatory pressure,
even more regulatory pressure
over the next three years.
Health systems are gonna have to adapt,
they're gonna have to
leapfrog in a number of ways,
and to get there, and
to thrive in the next,
or in the next three to five years.
Right, so let's start
with the data journey.
So Geoff, I'm gonna pick on you,
since we have your chief data officer
in the audience, as well.
Talk to us about your data journey.
You started early, and which
was so refreshing to hear.
Tell us about your data journey
from 2020, 2021, what you've done on AWS
and where you are today.
- Sure, thanks Abbas.
And this is my fourth time doing this.
So if it gets stale, Abbas will
have me booed off the stage.
We started our digital
journey based off data,
when we realized healthcare
data is in silos,
there's proprietary system,
whether it's your images,
whether it's your call centers,
go across the board, all
your data is in silos,
and each application
wants to keep that data,
and keep that data that way.
And so we realize that if
we're going to be successful,
we had to put our data into a single place
that was safe, was secure,
as well as it needed to be in the cloud.
For those of us who have
grown up in healthcare,
a lot of what we do is moving data
from point A to point B, and
then from point B to point C,
and then do it all again
when we change the system.
And so now it's about
bringing the logic to the data,
rather than the data to
the different systems.
And so, we put together
a high trust certified
cloud, AWS platform,
had it audited by third parties,
had it audited by second parties
and had it audited by
our own security teams.
And then we started looking at that of,
if we get the data there,
then that is the point
that we can start to work on
how we integrate with other platforms,
how we start to build our
own applications as well as,
as innovation comes along,
we have immediate access
to those innovations.
And so, although some of our AI adoption,
a lot of it is us trying
it on our own building
and fail quick, succeed quick,
the data is there for us to do that.
And so that was how we began our journey.
We were a very young system,
so granted me the
opportunity to start over,
because we didn't have any infrastructure,
except for some legacy systems.
Had you have some more legacy,
I think the story might
be slightly different,
because you have significant
investments elsewhere.
- So what, Geoff, maybe
a quick follow up there.
Why, so you went with, just to get
the technology folks engaged
in the audience here.
You went with all native AWS you know,
what sort of was the
genesis of that decision
and any regrets?
- I think the genesis was, we want to,
the goal was to avoid technical debt.
Again, your teams are overhead expense
and I love my team members,
but I want them helping us
succeed, not having to babysit.
And so we did go as much
native AWS as we could,
in some instances that
was wildly successful.
In other instances, it's
been a partnership to say,
this isn't as good as we thought,
we're gonna have to go elsewhere.
And so, it really was about
trying to keep our limited resource
of a small organization
or smallish organization,
very efficient, very focused,
and then going outside of
that ecosystem when we had to,
rather than shopping for
the latest, greatest,
because that could then keep
us shopping all the time,
with lots of change in turnover.
And similarly, you already have your data,
you already have the systems,
it's just an activation
and code is infrastructure,
rather than, I need to buy
it, I need a new MSA, BAA
and every other legal document
that goes along with it.
- Yeah, right on, Raj,
let me go to you next, here.
So you are, you know, you walked into
a health system that had some, you know,
needed modernization on
the health plan side.
What was your thought journey?
And I, you know, we will
get into AI in a minute,
but like, you had the thought about
having a dual strategy on,
we need a modern data platform,
but we also need an AI factory.
So walk us through your logic,
and why, you know, why AWS?
What was your thought process there?
- Sure, so you know,
I've been in this role
for about two and a half years,
when I first came in and
I started looking, I mean,
if you don't do AI and automation anymore,
it's not just that, you know,
you're gonna fall behind,
but you simply will not be able to keep up
with the pace of change, the
regulatory changes, right?
And, you know, to do cost
optimization, all of that,
you need to be in the AI world anymore.
Now to do AI, like you
said, you need data.
So when I started looking at it,
I quickly realized that
this is gonna be a fun journey, right?
So, and what I mean by that is, like,
so we had numerous data warehouses,
one that we were lovingly
called, new data warehouse,
which was four or five
years in the making.
And it's a never ending project, right?
And the overall data quality
was like really, really bad.
Now, back in the day, I ran
the data warehouse practice
for KPMG and I've seen some horror shows.
This was like way, way
worse than any of that.
So, but in some ways that
made my decision easy to say,
I'm not gonna worry about
trying to salvage this.
Let me just quickly start
a cloud modernization
and start, you know,
slowly decommissioning
these legacy assets, right?
But at the same time, I didn't wanna wait
'till a year, two years,
to have my data platform
where I want it to be,
to start the AI journey.
So then we started
looking at AI use cases,
where we had a high level of confidence
in the quality of data, or
the data were unstructured,
like, you know, documents
and things of that nature,
where we could go at it, right?
So that was sort of how we approached it.
- Mike, let me go to you.
You were, I'm gonna quote
your Banner data platform.
Maybe, can you talk to us
about your decision making?
Why did you make the decisions you made
and where you are now?
- You mean, just around the data platform?
- Yeah, the data platform.
- Okay yeah, you know, I think,
much like all of you in the
audience and my colleagues here,
you know, we've come from an environment
where we had kind of, one of everything
and we've had, you know,
multiple, you know, data
warehouses of the future, you know,
things you can buy off the shelf,
things we construct ourselves.
And I think we quickly
realized that we're moving
from kind of, this in a
highly regulated industry
that was very dependent upon,
you know, systems of record,
meaning that this EMR was like
the center of the universe,
and the ERP is the center of the universe,
and we're moving to a different time,
where infrastructure becomes
more of the center of the universe.
And so with that,
we really wanted our
data all in one place,
and we wanted it to be able to be prepped,
and be able to be acted upon by AI.
Whether we buy that
directly from partners,
or whether we wanted to have that,
something we construct ourselves
and we can drive competitive advantage.
And so, Banner data
platform is really kind of,
our vision for kind of,
putting all of our data
under one roof, one giant
lake house or, you know,
however you want to say that,
primarily on Databricks on AWS.
And so, there's a lot of layers
there, a lot of technology.
But, you know, we wanted
to drive observability.
We wanted to drive, you know,
a new generation of code development,
and kind of, a new generation of kind of,
software development practices.
And so, this is kind of foundational tech
that we have another three years to say
that we're gonna have it all done.
So, this year was really
about clinical data.
So we have, you know, I'd
say a majority, if not all,
it's not quite end of December yet.
So all of our clinical data in the,
in Databricks in real time,
being real time updated.
And so now we can act upon that.
A lot of that's curated,
you know, into a way
that we can actually use it for AI.
We've got a lot of do work to do
on our health plan side of
the business, to do that.
Same with kind of administrative data,
but those are the kind of, coming years.
And so we're tackling that as we have,
you know, as we go forward.
But I think the decision is that,
data is your, probably
your most important asset
of the future, you know,
I would say domain knowledge,
how your work happens at your organization
and data, all three of those
being really important assets
to the future, and so we
really want to prepare
and be able to capitalize on that,
along the way, you know,
we're doing everything we can
to keep pace with the transforming,
you know, landscape AI,
but it's hard, you
know, but things change,
or accelerating very quickly.
And so, you know,
thoughts that we had
about the data platform
at the beginning of this
year, they've already changed.
And so I think the right thing to do is
to make sure you have great partners.
- Yeah.
- You know, AWS and Databricks
have been particularly good,
because they've really evolved
with us on this journey,
and they really enable us
to kind of think, you know,
to that next level,
when we're really deploying, you know,
generative AI across the organization.
- Yeah, we're gonna get into AI,
but we have to, obviously we
cannot have a session here
without either talking about
OpenAI, Anthropic or, or Gemini for sure.
But Andy, let me ask you like, we were,
we've talked, I think Mike brought up
a word, infrastructure, right?
And we've talked about
governance, you know,
from an AI perspective,
you're the chief AI and digital officer,
governance, culture and
infrastructure, right?
And I think that is becoming,
just from even today's
session with Matt Garman,
vitally important, the
infrastructure piece.
I think people have realized,
I think executives and
boards are now realizing
that infrastructure,
without infrastructure,
we can't really do anything.
We can't really get into the workflow.
But what's your thought?
I mean, we, a year ago today, you know,
from here today, we were talking about
ambient listening and imaging AI.
What have you done
at Advocate Health in
your AI journey so far?
- Yeah, so I think we realized,
and Mike brought it up, you know,
you've gotta be great
at the informatics and
the change management.
You've gotta have deep
knowledge of your data
and your clinical workflows.
You've gotta have a data
platform and the right security,
all of those things in place.
What I would say is,
the thing that has given us the most value
and speed to value quickest,
is our best place to care strategy,
which galvanizes, you know,
750 of our change champions
in clinical care with informaticist
and our AI development teams.
And so we go from pilot to full scale,
we think faster than most
because of that relationship,
and because of our governance structure,
although we're a new health
system, the third largest,
we have a centralized IRB,
a centralized governance structure,
and enterprise platforms and standards.
So we don't have, we spend a lot of time
on platform rationalization,
for the past three to five years.
And so we have less sources of that data
to get into the right place, curated.
And then, you know, when generative AI
exploded onto the landscape, you know,
two and a half, three years ago,
we focused a lot on the framework
for how we review it
and monitor it at scale,
closed-loop process, we actually
trademark that as fair AI,
we share it openly for
others to access and curate,
a closed-loop process,
multidisciplinary teams
that review those,
model cards for every single piece of AI
that we have in production,
models, watching models in
production, those type of things.
And we think that those competencies
in governance and change management
from informatics point of view,
allow us to go, and from
small pilot to full scale
very, very quick.
And our clinicians, you
know, it's interesting,
you would think that some
of the back office people
would be leading the charge.
Our clinicians are actually
leading this charge,
and now some of the back office areas
are trying to catch up.
So we're really excited about that.
And in the places where we've deployed it,
we've seen patient experience go up,
clinician experience go
up, turnover go down,
and we're starting to see the value
for these investments that we've made.
And we believe that the health systems,
and I think these health
systems are examples of that,
that make these investments now,
in all of those three
pillars of expertise,
we will differentiate ourselves
in markets and with our competitors,
pretty damn significantly
over the next 18 to 24 months.
We consider ourselves to be a
digital and AI first company,
and that'll be part of
our transformation agenda,
moving forward.
- Yeah, just Andy echoing that, I think,
I think the moves you made, for example,
for those who are not familiar
with the fair AI framework,
it is truly, we consider
it as well, best in class
and we should all, I think
it's, it is public, right?
- It is published, it is trademarked,
and it's out there for all to
contribute to and collaborate.
- Yeah, yeah but Andy,
just, I'm gonna dive deeper a little bit.
So, walk us through your
partnerships that you've had,
that you've built over
the last couple of years,
at least with, I'm just gonna throw,
Aidoc and a and a couple
of others as well.
Talk to us about the
partnerships you've made as well.
- Yeah, so it's interesting
because, you know,
before AI hit, you could
be in series A or B
and still have pretty significant
commercialization opportunities
or co-development opportunities.
Now, because of the volatility,
you've gotta get up to
early stage, early C,
to actually have the ability
to influence and do those things.
But I think Aidoc is a great example.
Huge AWS platform play for them.
We now have more medical
imaging AI at scale.
Aidoc says it's the largest in the world.
I don't know how they
quite come up with that,
but I'll take the accolades
on the stage with them.
We have 15 algorithms
in production today, foundation models,
and if you look at the
shortage for radiologists
and the burden and turnover
that's in that space,
I think, every radiologist
has three and a half to four jobs
when they come outta school.
And so we've seen the speed to treat,
and turnaround time
increase significantly,
where we have scarce resources.
And we're not just doing
that in radiology with Aidoc,
we're doing it in
pathology and cardiology,
and some of the other areas.
And it has profound impact.
You know, we've got cases
that we could highlight
of where it caught, on the
last three panes of a scan,
a PE or something like that,
would've gone totally undetected
and would've been life ending for someone.
And so we're really excited
about the benefits there.
Aidoc is a great example of that.
Aidoc actually serves as an advisor
to our board, and we do the same for them.
And we've got multiple other
vendors that we've bet on.
I do think it is about
picking the right partners in this space,
that you can co-develop and co-create,
and take it to scale.
- Wonderful, so maybe Raj,
I want to ask you your thoughts on this,
because you started, again, you
know, early in this journey,
you, you know, we talked
about an AI factory
and what does that mean to you?
And what is the construct for that
and what's the value realized?
How do you measure that, most importantly,
and how do you, you know, how do you,
and of course you've paired up,
I think the smartest thing was pairing up
with your chief operating officer,
but like, how, tell us about that journey.
- Sure, so you know, part
of, prior to this role,
I was at Optum for 12 years,
and one of the realization was that
you can't have, like to drive, you know,
enabling and transformative
capabilities like AI,
it cannot be just driven
by the technology leader.
You need a two-in-a-box type concept
with a business partner
who has skin in the game
and who is just as
committed as that, right?
So in this role, in the very beginning,
I roped in my chief operating officer
and I said that,
"Look, we have to do AI,
but we have to do it together," right?
And so that's been a great partnership.
The other aspect of our AI program
has been very, very focused
on value realization.
So we have a, we have about
40 use cases in production,
about 60, 70 in backlog, right?
The complete AI program
is fully self-funded,
and at this point as is returning 2X,
and in probably a couple months,
gonna be closer to 3X in,
you know, revenue generation, right?
So, and I'm sharing that
because with that mindset,
part of what I wanted to do was,
I'm very big, like, you know,
both Mike and Andy and everybody said,
on having strategic partners, right?
Like, I know that I
cannot do this on my own.
We are also a safety net health system,
so we don't have access to innovation labs
and deep pockets to
like go innovate, right?
So we've been very focused
on bringing in partners
who have that co-innovate,
co-develop mindset,
and it's been hugely successful for us.
So if you look at my teams,
you wouldn't know who my team members are,
versus who my partners are, right?
It's a really nicely formed team.
Now, the concept of, you know, AI factory
was very important for me,
because part of our
approach in AI also was,
once you prove out a
capability for a given use case
and it generates the value,
we started looking at the backlog to say,
what are the other use cases
where the same capability
could be applicable, right?
So then it's a rapid
deployment and you can scale,
but to do that you need
this AI factory model,
where you had dedicated paths
that can now take this
capability, tune it,
and rapidly deploy across these,
you know, use cases, right?
So while our AI program is only two years,
that is the reason why
we've been able to generate
almost, close to 3X in return.
We wouldn't have been
able to scale otherwise.
- Do you feel that your,
that your platform that you've built,
both on the data side and of
course the AI factory side,
you use a combination of, and you know,
I wanted to get this a real
conversation going about,
you use traditional AI,
you use generative AI,
you are multi-model, right?
- Yeah.
- You primarily use
Anthropic, right?
- Mhm.
- Claude, I think it's both 4.5 Opus
as well as Sonnet.
But do you feel that
you could do more there?
Like, what's your philosophy there on the,
on your LLM strategy?
- Yeah, so you know,
I've approached this
with the mindset that,
I'm gonna be more focused
on like, solving problems.
- Yeah.
- And solving it with
the cheapest capability.
To be very candid with you,
that also has the ability
to scale to the extent that
we need to scale, right?
- Right.
- So as an example, there are, you know,
there are models that,
at Optum I would have to have used that,
because of the scale that I'm used to.
I don't need that here, right?
So we were able to find models
that is like, 100X
cheaper than that, right?
So if I'm being fully transparent,
like, cost is a big factor.
And you know, I also want
the ability like, you know,
Mike eluded to things,
things are changing so fast.
I don't wanna lock myself into.
- Mhm.
- Hey, this is
where I want to be.
I'm looking at like,
what's good enough today,
what gets me time to market, right?
Speed to value, that sort of thing.
And then I also wanna build it in a way,
where if tomorrow there's a better option,
I wanna be able to swap it
out with very limited impact,
and adopt the new capability, right?
So our whole philosophy has
been based on, you know,
everything that we built is
with that foundational mindset.
- Love it, love it, Geoff what,
so there's much going on
in the state of New York
and Connecticut, right?
Just, lots of legislation, regulatory,
both at the federal
and state level, right?
So what, and you're obviously part
of a much larger health system as well.
Where are you on your AI journey
and you know, talk about some use cases
that have really provided
some value to you,
and what's your plan for 26 at this point?
- Thanks, and so I think for,
I don't know how many of you in here
are familiar with the
healthcare industry as a whole,
but if you look at the
healthcare industry,
productivity in the healthcare industry
has stayed flat for decades
and decades and decades.
And if you look at other industries,
finance, manufacturing,
productivity increases
year over year.
And so as we look at,
and sorry for the economics lecture here,
but as you look at,
20% of the nation's GDP
is invested in healthcare,
yet productivity has not
changed over all these years.
AI has been the lever.
What is it, I just, archimedes,
"Give me a place to stand and a lever
and I can move the world."
Or at least I can move a few people.
And I probably butchered that,
and may have borrowed that from a movie
I just saw on the flight.
Anyways, so from from that standpoint,
I think AI is a great enabler,
and we are seeing productivity,
I think whether it's
back office, clinicians,
they also understand they
can't meet the demand.
I think Andy mentioned radiologists.
There's a shortage of radiologists,
there's a shortage of nurses,
there is a shortage of everything
in the healthcare world,
which means then expenses go up,
because you have to pay premium
dollars to recruit and keep.
And so if we're going to be
successful in this realm,
we have to make sure again,
we can exponentially improve
the productivity of a
radiologist with an Aidoc,
or look at the data and how do
we use ambient, again, older.
But we see that that has returned
and has increased patient experience.
And so where we're looking
at Nuvance in Northwell is,
how do we take the data
out of our numerous EHR's,
create that single lake,
and then start creating those rags
to bring that data forward?
And so we have several programs.
It's the monitoring
that I'm seeing a boss,
that we really need to do a better job.
Data must have a meaning.
I think all of us love collecting data.
Data's wonderful, but if
you don't know what it means
while it's sitting there for you,
the models are gonna
return erroneous content.
And so from that standpoint,
I mean your own,
I used Claude the other
day to ask a question,
and it told me the wrong
year and the wrong score
and the wrong everything.
And so if you have it wrong,
you won't get the right results,
which in healthcare will kill a patient.
So we're looking at very much,
how do we make sure that
our data is well governed,
our lake is very well manicured?
And then applying it to rags
so that we start to
reduce the amount of work
for tumor boards,
reduce the amount of work for registries.
And that's really where we're focusing,
is helping the clinicians
get some of their day and
some of their life back,
while also looking at
some of the back office,
'cause clearly that is a huge opportunity,
but as I think everyone's said it already,
you have to have the partners,
and the partners have to be ready
to partner with you.
And without that, you're going nowhere.
- Alright, I'm gonna put you on the spot.
- Please.
- What is, and this, I would've
waited for the future one,
but you brought up something
and I can't resist,
what is, I know you are working on,
you may be working on rev
cycle, if I'm not mistaken.
- Yes, sir.
- What is rev cycle looking?
Forget three years,
well, by the end of 2026.
- Oh, I love thinking about the future.
You're not, this is not the answer
you're looking for, boss.
Rev cycle is hand-to-hand combat.
Again, if you're familiar with healthcare,
it's hand-to-hand combat,
because the insurers take
money outta their pocket
and give it to you for services rendered.
- You mean Raj, you mean Raj.
- Insurers.
- And Raj.
- Ruthless.
- Luckily, there's no state
overlap between you two, so.
- No, no, we're friendly most days.
So from, rev cycle going to
be about creating the agents
and creating the tools
to counter the very deep
pockets of the payers,
who also are incentivized
to deny your claims.
And Raj, I don't mean
that like, as a attack,
but it is very realistic,
because the more money
that sits in the bank,
you know this, the more it grows.
So by paying the surgery
cost for my new knee,
if I hold onto it a little bit
longer, that's more interest.
And so AI is going to be,
how do we get faster pre-authorizations?
How do we debate the denials,
and how do we take all our contracts
and maximize those contracts,
so we're getting paid what we should
for the services we render?
- Good answer, yeah.
- Thank you.
- Mike, so I'm gonna put you on the spot.
So you are doing, I happen
to know some inside baseball,
but you're doing some
extremely innovative stuff
in the AI space.
So, maybe talk about your AI journey
and what you're doing,
especially, you know,
especially with today's announcements
with Nova Sonic 2 and
what's happening there.
You know, AWS is itself
becoming an AI platform vendor,
versus an infrastructure provider, right?
So talk to us about what
Banner Health is doing there.
- Yeah, I think this, you know,
I love what Raj and
Andy were saying before
about a lot of the things
here about partnerships
and about, you know, lock-in
and so forth like this.
I think one of the key concepts, you know,
we recognized really early on,
was that data and process
and domain knowledge being what it is,
that when we think about AI,
we have to think about
it kind of end-to-end.
It's the answer to everything.
And that light took a long
time to go off in my head.
You know, you hear, oh, cloud code
can increase the productivity
it developed by 30%.
That's not really the
interesting part about it.
It's not really that there's
a productivity increase
or you're gonna, you know,
displace a certain function
or it's gonna, you know,
make something easier in rev cycle,
it's about thinking about that end-to-end.
And so it's like, you know,
I think when we were talking
with some of your colleagues
at PWC about, you know,
the early days in Amazon
when they kind of, automated
Java, you know, development,
and then they automated
the deployment of that,
and they automated the testing of it,
then they automated the
fixing of the testing.
And before long, there was
just a specification left,
and there was really no human in there,
but it was a kind of a complete,
end-to-end closed loop system.
And I think that's the kind
of journey that we're on
in healthcare, is to figure out,
how do we enable those
kinds of things to happen,
so that we can kind of,
automate that complete process?
And you know, we chose call center
as kind of, one of our
first areas to kind of,
really look at in that area.
And that's been at Nova Sonic,
we've been building on that
for a couple months now,
really kind of building
conversational AI at the front end.
And we've, you know, picked a couple of
really key use cases,
like how to, you know,
schedule appointment,
reschedule appointment,
cancel appointment,
all those kind of, calls
that kind of, come into a call center.
And we're really in the
process now of automating that
with conversational AI.
You know, my belief is,
call center isn't really just call center.
Call center is kind of everything.
When you think about, you know,
you're calling HR at your job,
or you're talking to supply chain,
you're doing anything inside your company,
it's really kind of,
acts like a call center.
You're going and talking
to another human being.
You're trading information,
you're getting answer.
A lot of that's gonna be automated
through the use of conversational AI.
And so we're really excited
about the work we're doing
right now with Amazon,
with Nova Sonic 2, you
know, Amazon connect
and really kind of, taking
a look at call center
a different way.
You know, I want to kind
of talk a little bit
about the people side of that too, is,
you know, I think there
was a lot of, you know,
recent research saying that the pace
at which AI is gonna roll out
is really, only constrained by the people.
If people all know they're
gonna lose their job to AI,
it's gonna be really hard
to kind of, really do that.
And so, how do you kind of,
create an environment where,
you know, people can help
automate themselves, have a job,
and move on to the next part of automation
in a health system, and have,
play a substantial role into
that, get the retraining.
And so we're right now in the process
of really focused on the
culture aspect to this,
and the retraining aspect to this,
because there's a lot of,
as that turnover happens,
it's gonna happen rapidly.
We're gonna figure out, you know,
areas that we wanna focus on.
We wanna automate things,
but how do we kind of create
that workforce of the future
that has those skills
of, you know, curiosity,
that has the skills of
continuous learning,
that has the skills
of really being able to
help us automate that.
So I think that's kind of,
part and parcel to this journey of AI,
is really your organizational culture.
And I think the last thing, you
know, I just say on that is,
we're a big believer in
building it ourselves.
And so, I believe
that your competitive
advantage in healthcare
in any business, is gonna be
about your domain knowledge
that you have of your own
institution, how it functions,
how it works, and the data
and how clean that is,
and how that's gonna be acting on AI,
and how you can build and automate that,
internal to your own organization.
Now, I'm not saying you have to
out-innovate the marketplace.
There's no reason to not use partners,
but I'm a big believer in,
it's kind of like the old BPO model.
Like, when you think about
business process outsourcing,
you kind of lose a little touch
that you're really kind
of claiming to the world,
maybe that's not my core business,
maybe I don't really need to
do that piece and function my company.
So I think with AI, you gotta be
really thoughtful in your approach
about when you bring in a partner,
and that's gonna do all
the AI on your behalf,
is that something that you really,
you need a core competency
in your organization to do?
Is it a bridge strategy
that you're gonna build it in the future?
Is it something you're gonna evaluate
and kind of pilot and learn from?
Those are all the kind of conversations
we're having right now,
about how we can take it,
leverage partners to the
fullest extent for speed.
And I have several colleagues
in the audience today
that would tell us, you
know, we gotta go faster.
We gotta be able to enable the business
to kind of, think through
things and innovate
at a business level.
And that is sometimes
done through partners,
but we also gotta be able to,
where there's competitive advantage,
where we wanna drive distinction,
be able to build that
internally ourselves.
- Love it, Andy, I'm gonna turn to you
because I think you're innovating
at a breakneck speed here,
and I think one of the,
I think Mike mentioned
workforce of the future.
Tell us what your secret sauce is there,
and your partnership model just
internally, within Advocate.
- So you do need partners.
You know, if you're the person
that's leading digital
or AI transformation,
especially with the AI component,
you're either viewed as Santa
Claus or the Grim Reaper.
You're either bringing them great tools,
or you're there to take their jobs
and help get reduction.
And that's not a place
you wanna stand at alone.
And so I think,
relationships and partnerships
are really important.
Fortunately for us, and I know
many of the other panelists,
it takes the CEO taking a position to say,
AI will be the operating
model for the future,
or how we're gonna get to
transformation in healthcare.
So we do have to, we want
to be able to grow volume,
outcomes and profitability at a scale
where operating expense does
not go at the same level.
And if you look at healthcare today,
you normally grow major
acquisitions and activities,
margin stays the same,
and that's how you get to a
bottom, a different bottom line.
That's not gonna work in the future.
And if you look at,
I talked about the best
place to care strategy
with the clinicians,
I do have another partner that's
the chief clinical officer
who has nursing and physicians.
But I have another one,
which is Nakesha Lopez,
which is our chief people
and culture officer.
And she has a, it'll
be trademarked as well,
workforce of the future.
She's calling it, work forward.
And our AI factory will
laser focus on the areas
that have the biggest
opportunity for transformation.
Mike just spoke about the contact center,
that is clearly one of our
pods in this environment.
Revenue cycle is another,
and we will systematically
go through it role by role,
about what can an agent
first approach do to this,
and what is the new work
that they have to do,
and how do I get them there?
We're excited about that
in some of these areas.
Contact center and
revenue cycle, you know,
turnover rates are between 18 and 35%.
So it's not necessarily
about eliminating jobs,
if you just don't rehire through attrition
over the next three years,
the productivity benefit and
outcomes will be significant.
And so we're excited about that.
I would say we're,
as it relates to the
internal messaging on this,
and getting it right with our teammates,
it's gonna launch in Q1 of next year.
We have a lot of work to do that,
the places that clinicians
are leading the charge,
they know the shortages are so high,
that AI's just gonna help
eliminate the shortage.
The back office members
are a little bit, you know,
they're like, okay, what's
gonna happen to my role?
So I think you do have to enlist
the hearts and the minds
of the right leaders
on this journey, and the
right frontline teammates
to be a part of that charge.
So it's top down on the big uses cases,
but also citizen-led
development in certain areas,
as a bottom up, to galvanize
the interest for them.
And there's some overlap,
but really excited about
what that's gonna look like.
But you don't wanna be
leading this change alone,
that's for damn sure.
It's a lonely place to be.
- Right, right, so I'm gonna,
for those that don't read
Werner Vogel's, CTO of Amazon's yearly,
sort of, 2026 predictions,
highly, highly recommend that,
he, I'm gonna quote what
he posted last week,
"Instead of human in the loop,
it now should be, AI in the human loop."
And that's a fundamental
shift to what we've done
for the last 20, 30 years,
is build workflows and processes
around people and technology.
Well, let's, we should
take another look at that
and we will, and Andy,
I know you're chomping at the bit.
- Yeah, I was just gonna say,
we just launched seven use cases
in our contact center space,
which are really about
care management and care coordination,
and it's AI first,
with escalation and on
and off ramps to humans
that can handle it.
So you know, I don't ever
want another situation
where the first call or
the first text message
is on behalf of a skilled
nurse or a provider.
It ought to be these technologies,
and then the right
escalations and oversight
to make sure that, when
it hits a critical point,
you've got a human in the loop.
But, and I can remember
saying that, you know,
with the clinicians, oh,
it's human in the loop,
human in the loop, human in the loop.
And now I'm sitting here going,
I gotta come up with a different
bimodal strategy on this,
because that can't be
the way we move forward,
because we'll only get the
three to 5% productivity gains.
We won't get the transformation
that we're supposed to get.
- That's right, that's right,
Raj I'm gonna turn to you,
because you know, you have, you know,
we talk, you know, in the
consulting and the professional services
and the, in whatever you want to call
consulting and the forward
deployment engineer now, right?
But it is, you talk
about, you embody a quote
that our senior partner
said in an article.
"You want progress, but not perfection."
And I feel you've embodied
that over the last two years.
Talk to us about what that
means to wealth sense,
and part of, what was your
vision to actually do this?
Like, incremental benefit
versus a large benefit,
all at once.
So, talk to us about your journey.
- Yeah I mean, part of it is
just how I'm wired, right?
I have a bias for action.
I have very little patience
for analysis paralysis,
'cause most of the time,
in a majority of the input that
you need to make a decision
is already in front of you.
Are you gonna make that
decision or not, right?
And then you have to be comfortable
adapting as, you know,
things change, right?
So that's always been my approach.
And the other thing is, again,
I didn't have the luxury,
because of the financial
stress of the health system,
and safety net and all that,
to innovate and test and do
a lot of POC's and stuff.
I wanted the ability to like,
pick one or two as we
were just kicking off,
and just absolutely hit home
runs and drive the value.
Because in the very beginning,
you need to build credibility
with everybody, right?
So there's a lot of apprehension,
like, everybody talked about it, about AI.
I wanted to get past some of that,
and demonstrate the value
realization there, right?
So, that was fundamentally
how I approached it.
And part of it was like, you know,
to ultimately get the true unlocking of AI
and the value realization,
you need to do a complete
business process reimagination.
If you are taking the same
crappy business processes
that you have, and you're
looking to automate,
yeah, you can find efficiencies,
15% at this point here, 20 percent there.
But you have to be able to step back
and say like,
"How should this be
completely redesigned?"
Like Andy and Mike are now
saying, AI first, right?
But to do that you have to like,
earn trust and credibility,
and build relationship
where people are willing
to come to the table.
But at the end of the day,
that to me, is my biggest challenge now,
because we've established
a really strong program,
but there's still a
healthy fear in terms of,
'cause you don't, you know,
when you look at this
business process very clear,
like, these steps should just go away,
but there's a direct people impact
that is tied to those steps, as well.
And it's easy to say
that we will train
everybody in AI and stuff.
Some people are just not able to
or willing to, right?
So those are some of the
things that I would say,
you know, to always keep
in the back of mind,
that the change management aspect of it,
this is why AI cannot
be a technology push.
You need to have the chief
people officer, right,
your chief operating officer,
like, you need that team
to help the organization like, you know,
get where it needs to.
- Right, right, Geoff, this is,
so I know you and I have talked about
what Raj exactly said, right?
Don't agentify legacy dysfunction, right?
How do you go into a complex organization,
you know, whether it's, you know,
regardless of size of health
system, it's still complex.
How would you approach
this from a partnership?
And how is AI impacting your people?
I mean, I know it's from a
software engineering perspective,
it's reshaping the entire industry, right?
And it's reshaping consulting,
it's reshaping all
software product as well.
How do you approach it and, or,
how, how will you approach it?
- So, a couple different levels.
I have a personal model
that's not based off a movie,
that, I just look for soft targets,
where are the soft targets?
You see them all around your organization,
whether you're in healthcare,
whatever your specific business is,
you see the soft targets,
what is not working well?
And most of the time you then find,
who is the partner that
wants to solve this with me?
Usually they're reaching out to you,
but there is, I think Andy said
Grim Reaper or Santa Claus.
There's a lot of magical
thinking about AI.
I mean, there's a lot of hype,
but the reality of, how
do we make this practical,
as Raj said, is process engineering,
process identification, change management.
I think you've, I've heard
the word change management
uttered a couple times.
People have to be prepared for that.
And so when you find those soft targets,
then it's finding your partner and saying,
"Can we create a solution together?"
And we deployed a
solution with our HR team.
It wasn't fancy, it wasn't sexy,
but it was putting together
and reducing some of the headcount,
or not the headcount,
but the amount of calls coming in,
so we could create answers.
The product needs to be trained better.
And so how do we work
with that partner to say,
how do we become better at this?
What is their responsibility?
And then, are they going to own it
within the company, as well?
I don't know how the other
gentlemen are seeing it,
but sometimes AI or
technology is mine to own,
and when it works, it's
theirs to take credit,
and when it fails, it's ours to fix.
And so I think that partnership again,
is said over and over again,
is going to be very important,
but it's making sure
that you have the tools and the agents
to rework that process.
And if you have partners
that don't have the vision
for process re-engineering,
scrap it, scrap it, start over,
find those soft targets
who wanna work with you
to make that change.
- No, no, you know,
fail fast, learn from
it and rinse and repeat.
- A hundred percent.
And again, the willing
partners, the process,
the technology go after, go quick.
And I think that's probably the one thing
that all of us on the stage,
and probably you all in here as well,
we opt towards action,
and if others don't want to act,
then they will be a barrier to that.
And so you must find a way
to get through that barrier,
so that you can have the adoption
of whatever technology is,
whether it's boring, old, I don't know.
- Yeah.
- ERP or it is AI to transform the world.
Am I gonna get canceled?
I've just locked on
ERP and payers, so.
- No, you're not.
- You're not.
- So if I get canceled
after this.
- You're not, Mike,
I know you're chomping at the bit,
but you have lots of
thoughts here, so what's?
- No, I agree, but I also
think there's, you know,
I think the whole, you
know, tech governance is,
moves too slow to manage
this tech right now.
I just really do, I can agree with Raj.
I think there's more citizen-led
AI development in the future, I really do.
- I hope so.
- I think.
- I think it, I think, you know,
it's kinda like, trying
to govern the internet.
When we put it out there
we didn't say like,
"Hey, you know, you can
only go to these websites
to look at information."
We let people, you know,
experiment, we let people go.
And I think this is gonna be so ubiquitous
in everything we do.
We're gonna have to have, you know,
enterprise class AI that's got guardrails
and got, you know, everything
there to kind of be,
you know, take those, the 80% use cases,
but there's a lot of
around the edge, you know,
type of stuff that we
just need to automate,
and we need to give the
tools to the business
and let them, you know,
go forward with it.
You know, in a safe fashion.
But I'm a big believer that, you know,
sometimes this is, you've gotta prioritize
where you put your resources in tech,
but you've also gotta move fast.
And I think that that speed piece
is something we're grappling with.
Like, how do you change
the IT tech operating model
to really enable, you know,
a faster pace of deployment?
- Yeah.
- I couldn't agree more.
- Yeah, Andy, so I know we're
all running out of time,
but final thoughts from your side.
How do we, how are you looking at 2026,
given that every month,
stuff changes every month,
we're on, hopefully on the path to AGI,
and what is the first
quarter, what is 2026
look for you in this area?
- Yeah, so I think that if you,
I'm gonna break it into
two or three categories.
The first one is that, you know,
we believe that every clinical caregiver
that's touching a patient or a customer,
should have augmented, assistive AI
at their fingertips,
over the entire ecosystem
of the work that they do.
And we also believe in
citizen-led development
on these type of activities.
If I go back to the pandemic,
when we had a common enemy and an urgency,
we've moved more tech in 12 to 18 months
than we did in our past 10 to 15 years.
If it wasn't for the pandemic,
virtual would not be commonplace.
There used to be disbelief
that virtual care was not a
replacement for in-person care.
Bullshit, it is a replacement
for in-person care,
or at least a first and
second and third choice.
And so our data shows that today.
So I think you'll see us
continue mass deployments
in the clinical ecosystem.
I think that the AI literacy, you know,
the best way to raise AI literacy
is have them using it and
playing with it every day.
And so, but if you don't
make the investment
in the platform and the data systems,
you can't give them a safe way to do it.
The other thing is that,
if you don't give them a safe way to do it
with those platforms,
they will find a way around you to use it
in all kinds of unsecure places.
So your safest thing is
to give them a citizen-led
development safe place to do it,
to protect yourself.
I think the third thing
is doing the hard work
that we've never done well.
And I thought Geoff was gonna talk about
his first leader in the
performance improvement space
that he worked with, some guy,
and we worked together,
and Geoff came from the
performance improvement side,
that work of re-engineering
and not spreading,
not spending your talent on three to 5%,
and really focusing on
the hard re-engineering,
is where we have to go.
We believe that,
we've got 29 million
inbound phone calls a year,
15 to 20 million outbound a year.
We believe that 65 to 70% of
that should go away on people,
average panel size for
a primary care provider,
where there are mass shortages
in care and health inequities,
2,500 panel size, what
if I can get it to five
in the next two years?
What if I get it to 7,500?
What if your health system
could make primary care profitable
or a new version of that?
Those are some of the things
that we're looking at.
It's just not about efficiency innovation,
it's about business model transformation.
- I love that, so pretend like, it's COVID
and move fast like it's COVID.
I love that, Raj, final thoughts?
- No I mean, I'll just echo this.
Speed to market and speed to
value is everything, right?
And you know, just,
I also wanna hit what Mike said.
You have to enable people to like,
come into this AI world
and start participating, right?
On one hand we say that,
we want business to be
willing and adopt AI,
but then we like tell them,
don't do this, don't do that, right?
These two messages
don't, sort of jive.
- We're the, no, police.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- So it doesn't jive.
So, now, I would just echo what Mike said.
- Geoff, final thoughts,
some predictions for 2026?
Apart from the Lions winning it all.
- Yeah, ah no, thank you.
I think for 26, again, just
you've already heard it,
it's going to be about
change, more change.
We can't keep up, you can't keep up.
Whatever you're working
on is gonna change.
And so I think it's being flexible
and clinging onto a quick life cycle,
purchase what you know
you can use immediately
for the next three years.
Don't get sucked into tech debt.
I think that's would be my advice.
And then for us as a health system,
we're now merging in our
two technology stacks.
And so it's about how to
take core competencies of
our deep data knowledge
with some of that
citizen-led of Northwell.
Bring those togetherm
and can we really start
to bring that forward?
And so I'm excited for what we're seeing.
But again, it's, if you don't know it,
you probably are getting
phone calls from a nurse,
and that same nurse has to see you.
That's not how we should
be using our staff.
And so, as these gentlemen
here spoke about,
it is about reducing that load
and making care to our communities a joy
for these caregivers.
Not a pain in the backside.
- Mike, final thoughts?
Any predictions for next year?
- You know, I know we're in
a tough time in healthcare,
and I think this is the kind of,
the year to make or break it.
- Yeah.
- You know, you gotta
be deploying the tech
and there's a lot to do in 26,
because, you know,
the regular changes
coming a couple years out,
you know, this is the year.
So I think there's gonna be
a lot of progress made in
our industry, you know,
I look forward to, you know,
hearing what all my colleagues do here,
you know, the time is now.
So I think I'd say, you know,
this is a pivotal moment in healthcare
and I, you know, I hope that
the tools we have with
generative AI, you know, cloud,
all the partnership, all the advanced tech
we talked about here, are able to
really put us back on top
of where we need to be.
We have a goal
to reduce administrative
burden by 50% by 2028,
and that goes across the board
for all of our clinicians,
about all of our, you
know, all of our staff.
And you know, that's a real goal.
And we really want to
bring the joy back to practicing medicine
for our clinical staff.
We want the patients to
be more highly engaged.
We want to give 'em better, you know,
information and better
content, more, you know,
eyes on the patient, not on the screen.
And so we, we really feel like,
this is the moment of transformation.
And so I am, you know,
I feel like my whole career
has kind of come down to,
finally we're in a position
where we have the tools,
the technology to actually
take the vast amount of
knowledge in healthcare
and really put it to great use.
- Yeah.
- And you know, be in
service to the patients
to make healthcare easier,
which is really all of our missions.
- Yeah, there was, just to echo that Mike,
there was a recent VC case
study on, I think it is,
it was Menlo Ventures when they said,
"Healthcare is the number
one, maybe number two,
but number one, sector industry
where generative AI is being
used for transformation."
Because we all feel that this is,
traditional AI was good,
but this is so tangible,
so action oriented,
that this is our, I think 2026
is gonna be a very
transformative, actionable year.
We can make a real impact to
the health system, alright.
But thank you again.
Thank you to the panelists.
- [RAJESH] Thank you.
- [ABBAS] Let's, join me
in a round of applause.
(audience applauding)